samedi dernier les pompiers ont
découvert dans son appartement du 16e
arrondissement de Paris le corps sans
vie de Valentin 21 ans mort dans d'atroc
circonstances et il a été tué à coup de
couteau très probablement c'était une
scène de crime assez assez violente
l'étudiant passionnée du petit écran qui
aimait assister aux émissions de
télévision et qui a été retrouvé dans
une mare de sens et décrit par ses
proches comme un jeune homme sans
histoire et Penta comprendre les raisons
de ce meurtre Valentin c'était une
personne d'une générosité incroyable une
curiosité mais aujourd'hui grâce à
l'utilisation de la téléphonie et des
caméras de vidéosurveillance l'affaire
semble avancer
à son domicile ce matin à Paris de
Valentin notre stagiaire du public un
homme en garde à vue que sait-on
merci Michel Marie d'être avec nous
un homme vient donc d'être passé en
garde à vue dans cette affaire pour quel
motif
il est le suspect numéro 1 dans
l'enquête de la brigade criminelle
ça a commencé la garde à vue a commencé
ce matin donc c'est très récent
et pour comprendre cette garde à vue et
un peu l'enquête de de la police font
revenir sur
ce week-end c'est à dire ça la nuit de
samedi à dimanche
les policiers avaient finalement trois
choses intéressantes pour enquêter c'est
la scène de crime alors on va la
rappeler la scène de crime pour noter
les spectateurs elle est extrêmement
violente elle est très violente c'est
une petite chambre de bonne parce que ça
joue aussi ça a joué aussi dans
l'orientation de l'enquête
c'est après c'est la police technique et
scientifique qui fait la différence mais
on sait maintenant pour des raisons que
j'ai expliqué dans un instant que le
suspect est resté un certain temps à
l'intérieur sur cette chambre donc il va
forcément laisser ou de l'ADN ou des
empreintes digitales ou ne serait-ce que
l’arme du crime a été retrouvé sur place
c'est un couteau
donc ça c'est le premier élément
deuxième élément c'est que on a un
voisin un habitant de l'immeuble qui est
arrivé
au petit matin
et qui a été obligé d'ouvrir la porte un
individu qui était capuché qui avait une
capuche sur la tête et qu'il n'avait pas
les codes d'accès et il était un peu
menaçant donc le le locataire enfin le
l'occupant de l'immeuble a eu la
trouille et il lui a ouvert
il lui a ouvert la porte et ensuite le
le l'individu s'est dirigé vers le
deuxième sas
de sécurité et le l'occupant de
l'immeuble a appelé la police d'accord
en disant voilà j'ai été un peu menacé
par l'individu qui m'a un bon réflexe
obligé de rentrer dans l'immeuble le
faire entrer dans l'immeuble là-bas du
16e arrondissement est arrivé sur place
elle a tourné elle
a malheureusement rien constaté et elle
est repartie en faisant une mention
comme quoi
pavéne recherche mais en tout cas
déplacement pour rien
et c'est un peu plus tard que les c'est
beaucoup plus tard d'ailleurs ces trois
jours après le samedi en fin de journée
que les copains de Valentin vont
découvrir puisqu'ils étaient inquiets
puisqu'ils répondaient pas aux appels
vont aller à son domicile trouver des
traces de sang sur la porte appeler les
pompiers lesquels pompiers vont ouvrir
la porte et là on va découvrir la scène
de crime qui est un malheureusement un
véritable carnage puisque on sait
maintenant qu'il a reçu 18 coups de
couteau 18 coups de couteau 18 coups de
couteau
et on dit voilà quand il y a énormément
quand un acharnement comme ça
voilà on pense pencherait pour quoi
c'est quoi c'est on dit souvent dans les
meurtres amoureux sentimentaux
c'est évidemment une hypothèse
la brillade criminelle est en pleine
enquête donc c'est compliqué de savoir
le profil du suspect c'est quoi alors ça
je ne sais pas ça alors là je sais qu'il
a 24 ans c'est tout ce que je sais et
qui connaissait Valentin
l'autre information qu'on a qui est
importante c'est qu'il est resté au
moins trois heures
dans cette petite chambre d'accord
puisque le voisin dit en gros que il a
été obligé de donner l'accès de d'ouvrir
l'accès à l'immeuble à cet individu à 5h
du matin ou 5h10 et
la vidéo le voir sortir à 8h30 d'accord
donc on a le créneau horaire donc a
priori ils connaissait a priori ils
avaient Valentin n'avait pas envie de le
voir sinon lui aurait laissé libre accès
à l'immeuble et à son appartement donc
il se connaissait et ce qu'ils étaient
en train de se disputer en tout cas si
on restait trois heures ensemble